Ich bin Nuran Afji. Ich bin die Dienstabende der Aufzusehsitatsung.
Und ich bin gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegesicht des Übungen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, natürlich.
Demenzibitablad.
Ja, danke schön.
Wenn Sie etwas nicht verstehen, können Sie Ihre Fragen, können Sie,
können Sie Fragen stellen.
Und bevor Sie mir über Ihre Beschwerden erzählen,
möchte ich ganz schnell einfach allgemeine Fragen stellen.
Okay.
Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Paul Müller.
Paul Müller.
Herr Müller, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 69 Jahre alt.
69.
Und wann genau sind Sie geboren?
Am 18., 9., 53.
Und wo wohnen Sie?
Ich wohne in Rheine.
Rheine.
In welcher Stadt wohnen Sie?
Und welcher Straße macht Sie?
Ach so, welcher Straße.
Ich wohne in der Felsenstraße 17.
Welche Straße?
Felsenstraße 17.
Und Hausmann?
17.
Okay.
Und wie groß sind Sie?
Und wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ich bin 1,74 m groß.
Ja.
Und ich wiege 83 kg.
Okay.
Sind Sie perihratet?
Ich bin verheiratet, ja, ja.
Und haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, wir haben zwei Kinder und sogar schon ein Enkelkind.
Oh, sehr gut.
Und was sind Sie vom Beruf?
Ich bin jetzt zum Glück geredet.
Was haben Sie früher gemacht?
Ich habe als Angestellter in der Verwaltung gearbeitet.
Herr Müller, was führt Sie zu uns?
Welche Bestellten haben Sie?
Ja, ich habe so eine ganz unangenehme, schmerzhafte Stelle
an meinem Bein.
Und zwar am Innen am Knöchel, auf der rechten Seite,
am rechten Bein.
Und ja, da ist schon seit vielen Monaten immer mal
so eine kleine offene Stelle.
Aber das wird jetzt irgendwie immer größer.
Herr Müller, können Sie bitte sagen,
wo die Schmerzen am stärksten sind?
Ne, also, Innen am Knöchel, da wo diese offene Stelle ist,
da tut das weh.
Und jetzt läuft mit einmal da auch so komische braune Flüssigkeit raus.
Wo ist die offene Wunde?
Eine offene Wunde, ja.
Die habe ich halt schon ganz lange.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Wunde?
Die habe ich schon, klar, schon neun Monate,
in dreiviertel Jahren habe ich die schon.
Aber jetzt ist das mit einmal schlechter und größer geworden.
Im rechten Bein.
Am rechten Bein, ja, am Knöchel, im Innen.
Okay.
Und haben Sie Blutung in dieser Wunde?
Nee, geblut, das hat das eigentlich nie.
Aber das war auch, ja, das war immer nur so ein bisschen feucht.
Aber jetzt läuft da richtig Flüssigkeit raus.
Jetzt habe ich gedacht, ich muss da doch mal zu Ihnen kommen.
Ist das eidlich?
Nein, ich glaube nicht.
Nee, das ist kein zu gelber Belag drauf.
Aber da läuft jetzt halt so Flüssigkeit raus.
Haben Sie Fieber, Schüttelprost, Nachschweiß?
Nee, das habe ich eigentlich nicht.
Haben Sie begleitende Symptome,
die von denen ich wissen sollten?
Na ja, also die Schmerzen strahlen halt so ein bisschen aus.
Und das Bein ist irgendwie auch dicker.
Und fühlt sich so ein bisschen gespannt an.
Und die Haut, ja, jetzt in den letzten Tagen
hat sich die Haut auch ein bisschen dunkel verfärbt.
Und die Haut sieht irgendwie nicht mehr gut aus.
Ja, also, die haben Haut verfärbt.
Ja, da unten an dem rechten Unterschenkel halt, ne?
Sonst nicht, nur da an dem rechten Bein.
Ja, nur am rechten Bein, Unterschenkel.
Und haben Sie auch Schmerzen?
Ja, natürlich tut das auch weh.
Am Anfang war das nicht so schmerzhaft,
aber jetzt tut es schon richtig weh.
Deswegen habe ich auch gedacht, ich muss mal jetzt was tun.
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzskalibrikum 1 bis 10,
wenn 1 sehr leicht schmerzt ist, 10 unerträgliche Schmerzen?
Ja, soll ich sagen, in der Mitte vielleicht so bei 5, ne?
Das sind schon ordentlich Schmerzen, ja.
Und hat es denn Sie früher solche Beschwerden zum Erschmerzen?
Ja, also früher hatte ich ihn noch nie so eine offene Stelle.
Und dann habe ich auch gedacht, es heilt auch wieder zu, aber hat es eben nicht gemacht.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen oder mit dem Stuhlgang?
Ja, also mit dem Stuhlgang hin und wieder muss ich da mal so ein bisschen nachhelfen.
Dann bin ich ein bisschen verstopft, aber sonst geht das eigentlich alles noch.
Ja, Sie haben Verstuppung.
Ja.
Und haben Sie, leiden Sie unter Schlafsstörungen?
Ja, so besonders gut kann ich nicht schlafen.
Und jetzt die letzten Tage, es ist tatsächlich auch noch schlechter geworden,
weil das jetzt auch noch das Bein irgendwie weh tut und ich nicht mehr so richtig weiß, wie ich liegen soll.
Aber ich schlafe, glaube ich, auch schlecht, weil ich mich auch immer zwischendurch um meine Frau kümmern muss.
Die ist ein bisschen hilfsbedürftig.
Und wenn die da nachts irgendwie Hilfe braucht, muss ich mich immer um sie kümmern.
Da muss ich auch schon mal zwischendurch aufstehen.
Deswegen ist meine Nachtruhe sowieso ein bisschen gestört.
Ja, ich verstehe, Herr Müller, leiden Sie an chronischen Erkrankungen?
Ja, also ich hatte ein bisschen hohen Blutdruck, aber das ist eigentlich nicht so schlimm.
Und dann habe ich ein Burger mit.
Ihr sind jetzt Medikamente gegen Bulldog zurück?
Ja, ich weiß gar nicht, was dagegen ist.
Ich nehme Zofenopril, dann nehme ich eine morgens und abends, dann nehme ich HCT 25, eine morgens und Aspirin.
Könnten Sie bitte wiederholen? Zofenopril, eine morgens und eine abends.
Genau.
Wie viele Dosis nehmen Sie?
Ich meine, da steht Zofenopril 5 drauf.
5 mg.
Und Sie haben noch etwas gesagt.
HCT 25 habe ich auch noch.
HCT 25, eine morgens.
Und dann nehme ich noch Aspirin 100 einmal am Tag.
Nehmen Sie Aspirin morgens oder abends?
Mittags tatsächlich.
Und leiden Sie noch irgendwelche andere Erkrankungen?
Ja, ich habe also häufiger mal Probleme mit den Ohren und zwar trage ich ein Hörgerät und da habe ich jetzt immer wieder mal so Mittelohrenzündungen.
Das habe ich jetzt schon mehrfach gehabt.
Das ist ein bisschen unangenehm.
Und wurden Sie schon einmal operiert?
Ne, eine Operation hatte ich wirklich noch nie.
Vor 5 Jahren, da war ich mal beim Arzt, da durfte ich aber auch wieder nach Hause gehen.
Da hatte ich eine Thrombose in dem rechten Bein.
Im rechten Bein?
Da musste ich dann für eine Zeit lang so einen Strom tragen und Heparin erst spritzen und so was.
Aber das ist schon so lange her, da muss ich jetzt nichts mehr tun.
Ja, jetzt sind Sie behandelt.
Damals bin ich behandelt worden.
Und, haben Sie, reagieren Sie allergisch irgendwelche Medikamente?
Ja, bei Allergien muss ich ganz klar aufpassen.
Ich darf überhaupt kein Fisch und keine Meeresrüstern essen.
Also keine Muscheln, keine Krabben, da darf nirgendwo was dran sein.
Da kriege ich also Luftnot und das ganze Gesichtschwild an.
Und das muss ich wirklich dringend vermeiden.
Sie reagieren allergisch auf Fisch und Meeresrüchte.
Also alle Meeresrüchte, alles Getier, was im Meer lebt.
Und sind Sie geimpft gegen Corona-Bürch und...
Auf alle Fälle? Ja, ja klar, gegen Corona bin ich geimpft.
Und waren Sie in der letzten Zeit im Ausland?
Nein, nein, nein, ich kümmere mich ja um meine Frau, die sitzt im Rollstuhl.
Und da können wir gar nicht verreißen.
Rauchen Sie, Herr Miller?
Ja, seit 18 Jahren rauche ich nicht mehr.
Das ist ja so gut wie nicht mehr.
Also früher habe ich mir schon ordentlich geraucht.
Aber jetzt will ich schon lange nicht mehr.
Ja, Sie haben gut entschieden.
Früher, wie lange haben Sie geraucht?
Ach, eigentlich so mein ganzes erwachsenen Alter.
Bis kurz vor der Rente oder ein paar Jahre habe ich vorher aufgehört.
Also 30 Jahre waren das wohl?
30 Jahre.
Und wie viel haben Sie am Tag geraucht?
Ja, da habe ich schon eine Packung am Tag, habe ich schon geraucht, ja.
Trinken Sie Alkohol, Herr Miller?
Ja, gelegentlich mein Bier, das kann man ja eigentlich nicht als Alkohol bezahlen.
Sie trinken Bier?
Ich trinke hin und wieder ein Bier, ja.
Auch mal zwei.
Und Herr Miller, das ist eine Routinefrage.
Ich muss auch diese Frage stellen.
Nehmen Sie Drohne?
Ich drohe? Nein, nein, das habe ich noch nie gemacht.
In meiner Jugend ist mir das zwar mal angeboten worden, aber nie, nie.
Da habe ich immer die Finger davon gelassen.
Und haben Sie irgendeine Familie?
Ja, eigentlich sind alle gesund.
Meine Eltern sind natürlich hoch beta...
Also mein Vater ist schon vor vielen Jahren gestorben.
Woran ist er gestorben?
Ja, der hatte irgendwie so in den geilen Gängen,
der hatte eine Tumor und dann ging es eben ganz schlecht.
Aber der ist ja auch noch sehr alt geworden.
Und meine Mutter, ja, die ist jetzt so hoch betagt.
Und die hat vor fünf Jahren so einen künstlichen Damausgang bekommen.
Aber ja, die ist jetzt auch pflegebedürftig und ist im Pflegeheim.
Aber die ist dann auch schon wirklich fast 100 Jahre alt.
Lebt ihre Mutter noch?
Die Mutter lebt noch, aber die ist eben schon sehr, sehr alt.
Sie ist schon über 90.
Und haben Sie Geschwister?
Nein, die Geschwister habe ich nicht.
Und Sie haben gesagt, Sie haben zwei Kinder.
Ja, ja, klar.
Ja, die sind ja auch schon längst erwachsen, meine Kinder.
Und leben Sie mit Ihrer Familie?
Ich lebe mit meiner Frau zusammen.
Ja, habe ich ja gesagt, ich muss sie ein bisschen betreuen.
Und leben Sie in einem eigenen Haus oder in einer Wohnung?
Wir haben eine Wohnung.
Und treiben Sie Sport, Herr Müller?
Doch, ich jetzt in meinem Alter, nein, nein, ich mache keinen Sport mehr.
Früher bin ich mal zur Arbeit mit dem Fahrrad gefahren.
Und da habe ich auch mal so Fahrradtouren gemacht.
Aber so richtig viel Sport habe ich nicht gemacht.
Ich habe einen jungen Mann, habe ich mal Fußball gespielt.
Aber das ist alles schon lange her.
Ja, ich verstehe, Herr Müller.
Ja, ich habe alle mich wichtige Fragen gestellt.
Möchten Sie noch etwas hinzufügen?
Ja, ich möchte eigentlich nur wissen, was da mit meinem Bein los ist
und was man dagegen tun kann.
Weil so ist das natürlich schlecht.
Ich muss mich ja auch meine Frau kümmern.
Wenn mein Bein jetzt so weh tut, dann bin ich ja selber nicht gut dran.
Und das muss ja irgendwann wieder zugehen.
Was kann man denn da machen?
Herr Müller, ja, jetzt ist es zu früh etwas zu sagen.
Ich habe ja als erstes habe mir immer drei Schritte um eine richtige Diagnose zu stellen.
Bisher habe mir nur eine nächste Gespräche durchgebracht.
Ja, ich werde sie körperlich untersuchen, dann auch mal aufnehmen
und operative Diagnostik durchführen.
Das klingt ja gefährlich. Was machen Sie denn damit, Apparaten?
Ja, die operative Diagnostik sind nicht gefährlich.
Ja, ich würde wirklich Tonografie, oder auch karpitierte Tonografie untersuchen.
Und tut das weh?
Nein, das ist eine schmerzfreie Methode.
Das ist ja schon mal gut.
Kriegt man dabei Strahlen ab?
Nein, das klingt ja ganz gut.
Was kann man dann sehen?
Man kann die Gefäße beurteilen.
Man kann eine Verschluss in ihrer Gefäße gehen.
Ja, aber die Verschluss wäre ja durch, dann müsste man ja bestimmt etwas operieren, oder?
Ja, wir können jetzt nicht viel sagen.
Es hängt ab, die Diagnose.
Okay, ja.
Was bei den Untersuchungen rauskommt.
Ja.
Okay.
Gut, dann warte ich jetzt hier im Wartezimmer auf Sie.
Ja, und dann rufen Sie mich, wenn es weitergeht.
Ja.
Okay.
Kollegen, Fragen? Noch Fragen?
Bitte fragen Sie.
Ja, etwas.
Ich möchte noch mal fragen,
ob Sie Ihre Sicherheit präugelten?
Ja.
Wann waren Sie das letzte Mal beim Arzt und Wertschelleveruntersuchungen?
Ja, ich war lange nicht beim Arzt.
Ich holen mir immer nur meine Blutdruck-Tabletten ab.
Aber einmal im Jahr gehe ich eigentlich hin.
Und das ist jetzt schon ein bisschen über ein Jahr her,
dass ich zum letzten Mal da war.
Da ist Blutdruck gemessen und ja, ich sah Blut untersucht,
haben die auf und Urin haben sie auch untersucht.
Aber sonst ist da nichts passiert.
Blutzüge, durchgeführt worden?
Das weiß ich nicht, ob das auch mit untersucht worden ist.
Ich denke mal, das machen die automatisch mit.
Aber jedenfalls nicht irgendwie so eine Spezialblutzucker-Untersuchung,
wo man vorher ganz viel trinken muss oder so.
Hatten Sie diese Beschwerden am Anfang einen Unfall?
Ach so.
Ah, nee, das ist mit einmal von alleine aufgegangen,
diese kleine Stelle.
Ja, also zumindest habe ich das nicht gemerkt,
dass ich mir da weh getan habe.
Und das hat mich auch gewundert.
Deswegen habe ich auch gedacht, dass das halt bestimmt schnell wieder zu.
Aber das dauert jetzt schon so lange.
Wie viel Stufen können Sie steigen, bevor Sie stehen bleiben?
Na ja, doch eigentlich bin ich noch relativ fit.
Normalerweise laufe ich schon so 2 Etagen ohne Probleme.
Danke schön.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Hat sich Ihre Gewicht in letzter Monat verwendet?
Nein, auch nicht.
Ich muss gerade mal gucken.
Nee, nichts bekannt.
Der wies sich auch nicht so oft.
Hat sich Ihr Appetit verwendet?
Ein Appetit? Nee, du hast immer gut.
Ist Ihnen übel?
Nein, ich habe nur diese Schmerzen im Bein, wissen Sie, ja.
Und diese offene Stelle da.
Die Fristigkeit sieht aus braune aus, ja.
So bräunliches Zeug läuft daraus, ja,
und es klebt auch so ein bisschen.
Und, äh, hat eine...
wurden Sie...
wurden Sie gebissen?
Ja, von einem...
Insektienstich oder sowas?
Ja.
Von einem Hund oder...
Nein, keine Verletzung.
Seconds.
Nee, auch kein Zeckenbiss, nein.
Also nicht an dieser Stelle, nein, gar nicht.
Tatsächlich hatte ich diesen Sommer schon...
irgendwie vier oder so Zecken,
aber alle noch ganz klein, noch nicht angefangen zu sorgen.
Als das gespräch...
anfangen?
Ja, okay.
Äh, äh, äh, Frau Oberlösch,
Sie haben Sie Zeit für mich.
Ich möchte einen neuen Patienten...
über einen neuen...
einen neuen Patienten berichten.
Ja, gerne.
Wie haben Sie denn gesehen?
Ja, Paul Müller ist ein...
68-jährige Patient.
Äh, 1 Meter 74 groß
3,6 kg.
Äh, äh, äh,
die, äh, äh,
Hermülla, äh, Hermülla,
ich stelle dir, äh,
wegen Zeit, 9,6, 5,
10, äh, 5, 10, äh,
in der letzten Zeit, äh, äh,
seit 9,6, äh, 5, 10, äh,
eine Opene, äh,
in der letzten, äh,
unterstrengend, äh,
vor, äh, äh,
der, äh, äh,
der Patient, äh,
der Patient berichtet von, äh,
Hautverfärbung, äh, äh,
im betroffenen, äh, Bereich, äh,
und, äh, äh, äh,
er klackte über auf, äh, Schmerzen, äh,
äh, äh, äh,
die Schmerzen, äh,
liegen, äh, die Schmerzen würden, äh,
äh, fazem
Liegen, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh,
der Patient, äh, äh,
внешtät, äh, äh, äh,
ja, okay, kann man
Die Wunde, das die Wunde...
Was wollen Sie sagen?
Flüssigkeit.
Ja, dass die Wunde Flüssigkeit absondert.
Ja.
Also die Wunde wird größer und tiefer, das beschreibt der Patient.
Die wird schmerzhaft und seit kurzer Zeit tritt eben Flüssigkeit aus der Brunde aus.
Ja.
Und das hat er vorher nicht bemerkt.
Und...
Mittelohrensündung.
Mhm.
Und...
Zustand nach...
Zustand nach Thrombose in rechten Beinen.
Wie lange war das, ja?
Ich habe nicht gefragt, wann war diese Thrombose.
Aber ich kann...
Ich kann fragen, beide unter...
Aber jetzt nicht kürzlich, ne?
Nein, nicht kürzlich.
Schon lange.
Okay.
Und sie...
Nein, er reagiert allergisch auf die Fische.
Und die Allergie äußere sich aus...
äußere sich aus die Schmerz und haut auf die Schmerz.
Mhm.
Hautausstatt.
Der Patient sei gegen COVID-19 geimpft.
Mhm.
Und er sei nicht...
er sei seit 18 Jahren nicht braucher.
Nicht raucher?
Mhm.
Nicht raucher.
Und früher...
ja, Nikotin Abutl,
wurde mit 30 Fäcken hier bejaht.
Mhm.
Äh, er trink gegelegentlich,
biya,
drogener Abutl,
wurde fernlein.
Mhm.
Ihnen der Familienanamnese,
Er hat zwei Kinder. Er lebt mit seiner Frau in einer Wohnung.
Er treibt keinen Sport. Er sei angestellt, er sei rentner, früher angestellt in der Perfektion.
Die anerbrischen Angaben haben am ersten auch so viele Fronische, wennöse zuversieht.
Die Wunde, wie nennen wir das? Eine offene Stelle am Unterschenkel. Wie heißt das?
Wennöse, wennöse, Ukus kurres.
Was wäre der Fernsehdiagnostisch drin?
Als Fernsehdiagnostisch, perferiert Arterielle verslust Franzheit.
Was wäre noch eine Möglichkeit?
Dr. Gündis hat nach einem Blutzucker gefragt.
Was wäre schlimmstenfalls möglich?
Was machen Sie mit den Patienten?
Worauf achten Sie bei der körperlichen Untersuchung?
Beide.
Woher gucken Sie noch?
Was machen Sie mit der Schwellung?
Was machen Sie da?
Was machen Sie da noch?
Was machen Sie mit einem Band?
Was machen Sie mit einem Labortechnik?
Was müssen wir noch überprüfen?
Worauf achten wir da?
Was machen Sie mit einem Labortechnik?
Was erwarten Sie?
Was macht man erst mal darauf, dass die Wunde nicht verklebt mit dem Pflaster oder mit dem Verband?
Da kommt so ein Salvengitter drauf.
Was die Wunde abdeckt, aber nicht verklebt mit der Wunde.
Dann kommen entsprechende Wundauflagen drauf.
Da das hier eine nassende Wunde ist, was muss da noch drauf?
Wir müssen die Wunde drucken.
Was machen wir dafür?
Wir müssen saubkompressen haben, die die Flüssigkeit aufsaugen.
Wir machen erst das Gitter drauf, damit es nicht mit der Wunde verklebt.
Dann kommt eine Saubkompresse drauf, die die Flüssigkeit aufnimmt.
Danach kommt der Kompressionsverband.
Soll der den Kompressionsverband abmachen?
Eigentlich nicht.
Die Wunde ist wieder offen.
Das soll dauerhaft verbunden sein und auch kompremiert sein.
Wenn man feststellt, dass der Wende eine Wendose ist,
und man hat das mit Glück abheilungen gebracht,
dann kann man überlegen, ob man die Wunde behandelt.
Ob man das Glerotherapeutin macht oder die Wunde hierurgisch entfernt,
um das Ulkos damit trocken zu legen.
Dann bin ich gespannt, was rauskommt, was bei Ihren Untersuchungen rauskommt.
Vor allen Dingen bei den Laborwerden.
Gucken Sie auf alle Fälle nach dem Abstrich.
Dann halten Sie mich auf dem laufenden,
der Herr Müller in den nächsten Tagen anfangen.
Okay?
Alles klar.
Ich habe noch nicht diesen Fall gehabt.
Ich habe ja auch ein großes Räfert-Fahr empfellen.
Gut, aber es kann Ihnen ja passieren,
dass wenn Sie in der Prüfung sind oder auch wenn Sie im echten Leben
irgendwo als Arzt sind, kann Ihnen das passieren.
Dass Ihnen jemand seinen Bein hinhält und sagt,
gucken Sie mal, ich habe da ein Loch und da läuft Flüssigkeit raus.
Und das Loch habe ich jetzt bereits seit vielen Monaten.
Da ist man zwar nicht glücklich, aber es kann passieren.
Ja?